cuando el glamour se vuelve político
este domingo se celebra la edición
número 70 del certamen de belleza miss
universo el evento organizado en la
ciudad de eliat en israel ha despertado
todo tipo de choques geopolíticos el
rechazo se hizo sentir con fuerza en
sudáfrica desde donde manifestantes y
figuras políticas hicieron un llamado a
boicotear el concurso el gobierno
incluso le retiró el apoyo a la
representante del país africano la ley
la mesa' wayne o la ley
hemos hecho un llamado de atención a la
ley para que boicotea miss universo
porque se lleva a cabo en un estado de
apartheid nosotros como sudafricanos
podemos relacionarnos con ellos
saleh
entendemos la brutalidad que se nos
impuso y que presenciamos a diario
contra palestinos indefensos
y fans las cuales también unos reclamos
en contra de israel que también
resonaron en grecia cuando la modelo
rafaela plástica publicó en su cuenta de
instagram que decidía hacerse un paso al
costado del concurso a pesar de que
grecia asegurará que plástica no era la
candidata oficial
palestina no sólo estás en mi mente
todos los días sino que tienes el lugar
más hermoso en mi corazón para siempre
estoy decepcionada con mis universo por
esto una decisión que contrasta con la
polémica presencia de representantes de
marruecos y bahrein en el certamen unas
apariciones que responden a la
normalización de las relaciones de
dichos países con israel y que mandan un
mensaje implícito al resto de países
árabes al parecer este año el concurso
podría ser más político que glamoroso